[Music]
in foot-fetish news taken oh he does I
wish it was all foot finished news yeah
why sure because I just think that's so
funny I love foot fetish guys it's the
best submitted by a white Walker oh [ __ ]
we're coming I think it's next year it's
the last one yeah bring down forever I'm
a found below oh that's what you haven't
even watched it I forgot oh I actually
just actually just had this alcohol
called Johnny Walker white Walker and
it's like a promotional thing get ready
because it's the last season next year
what so that's part of the game so me
and Nikki did a video where we were my
brothers telling us
assonance Game of Thrones questions and
we're answering to catch people up on
the show but we don't know anything
about the show both of you yeah why well
watch it so when they start coming out
we could watch it together we used to
have viewing parties it was oh that's I
mean you don't want to be the guy that's
like 10 years late on like things like
breaking bad or like he doesn't want he
already is that guy some cool shows
brother I've not seen White Walkers you
guys wouldn't even know what oz art is
bro we watch both scenes I know but you
back up they shoot him back up because
they actually watch the thing that you
told them yeah you shitty friend
approval okay I'll watch I'll watch it
I'll watch it I want you know I've
wanted to watch it I just never had a
good mixer like that backed up watch
Game of Thrones and watch bloodsport
don't watch place for you're wasting
blood sport the Van Damme movie I see
blood sporting [ __ ] out of your mind
hey what made you think he didn't watch
blood splatter no no I watched one sport
too we don't say oh yeah there was a fun
sport to this blood sport town
deny me the life you should watch
Lionheart that's a Van Damme movie
oh I've watched it we had a mullet yeah
yeah it's good well he had a mullet like
half of woman that where he does the
splits with the two chairs that's every
movie come on every movie are there's
that hallway and then he does the splits
there that's like saying that's the
Patrick Swayze movie with the bar fight
it's like come on yes you ever see
Roadhouse no it's his best movie have
you seen a kickboxer shui and am with
the Academy Award winner John Casey I
haven't seen that one did you guys see
JCVD with the Kreitman okay a one-er
--nz over $100,000 a year by selling her
smelly socks would you guys sell your
smelly guys a sock smell worse when you
travel cuz that is when my [ __ ] reeks
dumb [ __ ] my hate it when I'm in a
[ __ ] plane and the dude takes off his
[ __ ] shoes mid-flight it's like if
you know you're pretty bad Mouse you
take it right when you [ __ ] sit down
but then the ventilation is better
during mid-flight then like worse look
at this it's simmering and like
humidifying and marinating and it's
sweating for food in there but they need
to bring the bowling alley spray they do
man [ __ ] hose it down you know you
know what if my method is I actually get
my deodorant and I rub it on my foot put
a sock on and then I rub it over that
too that's why yeah there sprays for
that you don't even have to put actual
armpit that's like if you're on the go
you know you don't have this carry you
can't keep yeah you can't bring that
well I actually do is just chop off my
feet that's a good that's a good at so
we have a bunch of athlete's friends and
then they'll come over and then we're
friends no friends and then they'll come
over and we're a house where you don't
wear shoes um so then they sit on my
couch and these are my nephew's too they
sit on my couch and it traps all the
[ __ ] foot odor and then we had the
little playpen for taiga and it's sponge
so it absorbs all this [ __ ] foot odor
oh that's when you get like 55 candles
and you light it like you're out of
church I've had it steamed already and
it just won't come out
yeah yo foot [ __ ] is like a boxing glove
[ __ ] like it's like really bad bacteria
is the smell of bacteria and steam and
heat it is disgusting yeah [ __ ] hate
it cuz I'll get smelly sv2 those are
sins bro sins are just watch rap in
there it's not bacteria it's a sin it's
everywhere that you got anybody if
you're like just walking around for a
long time it's gonna smell his don't
dough huh so he's the one who should be
selling that [ __ ] for 100 grand he's
like a war that's all day I also got no
why I also don't know my feet and socks
just never smell it's just spray a lot
but I do that just for fun I don't even
don't even need it dude that's like
seeing Jesus Christ on a piece of toast
it's like I wore these socks for a month
and they don't smell that should be in
the [ __ ] Smithsonian that's not
because your feet just don't purse
breath it because that's like how my mom
is her feet doesn't purse prater she has
really dry feet they get sweaty oh
really
how do you know that about your mama's
so strange because that very Drive we
did never my mom they don't stink my
feet didn't smell that medical thing
that she has she has to deal with
because her feet are all flipped up on
the bottom so try my feet why my bad
your poor your poor mom okay see you
actually can't sweat at all whoa so like
when we were younger when she was look
at what you did he so sad no we went to
parks oh [ __ ] I'm sorry here we go play
the music go ahead playing sad music
no but she she would have to be I used
to have to get ice packs and put it on
her neck because she can't purse pretty
so that's the thing that regulates our
yeah she's like a doll so she can't so
she we would have to cool dogs don't
sweat they gotta go we're all rolling
with it that's you sweat once would she
good no they don't have no they don't
have sweat clashes yeah they don't dogs
just don't have a wet or like clammy
she's just stinky I don't know if a dogs
just they can't I think she got fungus
or some [ __ ] damn cuz I'm like ain't no
dog sweat hot like a dirty foot that's
Alphonse mostly she got [ __ ]
bacteria growing her dude people men you
guys definitely brought her some broken
ass animals in general yeah like [ __ ]
meat loaf and his weird ass and then
[ __ ] fondant or smelling this fungus
funny wait why would somebody pay a
hundred grand for small a sauce this is
Roxy psych the cheese maker and he's
collecting it oh it's cuz she's
attractive I see end a video she has the
longest toes I've ever seen in my
[ __ ] life do her fingers wait how
many told you had oh I thought I kind of
see how long those are really long six
on each foot yeah that makes me wanna
puke dude why is you those are some cool
shoes those are cool shoes but dirty
socks dad dirty shoes I got some pale
ass shoes save some money Dan those are
[ __ ] dirty so she's a property
investor in a sock seller at the same
time someone once complimented her on
how her feet are so beautiful and so
does have nice feet so she know there's
a lot of different types of feet is that
a good [ __ ] I mean her nails are nice so
she's got nice nails like her foot is
all one
it looks very fit this is the shape of
her foot yeah it's very boxy yeah it's a
rectangle because for me a foot doesn't
play into at all if a girl's hot or not
awareness [ __ ] what [ __ ] like will you
put your feet together for me like if a
guy has ugly hat fingernails like that's
a big turn-off I wanna feel all Walker
and ya ugly fingernail that's hard you
still be still pull off I know but
that's hard you're good at looking ok
I'm just explaining my point of view
it's hard you can't imagine imagine how
you're giving you the answer everybody's
like nah you can't do it you're staring
into Paul Walker's piercing blue eyes
yeah it's like baby but then as soon as
he touches oh no I'm out no if they have
like those short and this is no offense
it's my preference yeah water with this
like and I see isn't it nail everything
over please stop
what if his fingers were like this it's
full of dirt it's like it's like half
it's like half fingers I can't do it
what if it's working a working man's
grip like heat like he's at the fire
department all day I don't care if
they're dirty like it I'll deal with
that cuz I mean you can just clean it
right but I'm talking about the shape of
the fingernails
together you were looking at my hand see
but they even passed first yeah I
noticed
all that [ __ ] right away Oh what are
your deal-breakers then so that's a
deal-breaker what else nasty press this
is after the fact already already I'm
telling you this which the bait and
switch man I never had fresh breath um
athletic body I can't do that either
I think that's the biggest ones a
non-athlete not an athlete that's like
the biggest and then I think with clean
hands the shape of the fingernails
wasn't ugly finger dirty fingernails
shapers like you guys all have nice
fingernails I've already seen it I agree
he does yeah you have good finger I have
no fingernail no but you still have good
fingernails
did someone that like though either bite
it too short or oh you're talking about
the [ __ ] stubby half fingernail me
that [ __ ] looks like a ham hock dude I
know what you're talking yeah I'm not
trying to make fun of anyone
everyone has their preferences this just
so happens to be much no guys with long
fingernails with a tell they don't cut
them very often I don't care about that
either because this shape is still cool
cuz I know when they cut it it's gonna
be the shape that I like I've been
turned off by feet but not turn on by
feet oh because those I saw troll feet
on a girl troll Fiat what does that look
like we'll think about it for a sec TIFF
fat flat short and stubby but it does
not match the person that has the feet
and that turned you off yeah is it
possible to have a girl's fine enough
the feet could be as busted as it oh I
you feel me gotcha yeah because it
doesn't match it's like why do you look
like this and your ankles you don't have
ankles first of all it just it's just
that's Katy's biggest turnout it's like
it's get ankles like when it's like a
cankle when there's like there's just no
shape yeah it's like oh yeah it looks
like a [ __ ] daikon
[Laughter]
[Music]